[Music]
straight ahead on lawn crime daily
new body cam video of gabby potato and
brian laundry where did he hit you
don't worry just be honest
i guess the eerie prediction officers
made about the couple's fate and the
federal trial of elizabeth holmes is
back in session how witness testimony is
shaping the case against a former
billionaire plus murder murder mystery
reports now claim maggie murdoch met
with a divorce attorney just weeks
before her murder and later search
history revealed he started a farmington
police department facebook page article
specifically referencing a 50 000 reward
for information leading to sasha krauss
the latest on the mennonite murder trial
out of arizona law and crime daily
covering court cases from coast to coast
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm brian buckmeyer along with terry
austin body camera video from a second
police officer is giving us new
information about what gabby petito told
officers about an incident between her
and brian laundry law and crimes
anginate levy is here with a video from
police in moab utah
brian this video is from that august 12
traffic stop where a 911 caller reported
seeing a man hitting a woman the
officers pulled over gabby petitto's van
and spoke with her and brian laundry
what's your name
a moab police officer spoke to gabby
petitto on august 12 after separating
her from brian laundry petito told the
officer she got stressed out and laundry
locked her out of the van
is there something on your cheek here
looks like did he get did you get hit in
the face
kind of looks like something like hit
you in the face
and then over on your arm
shoulder right here
that's new huh
have a new mark
oh yeah i don't know can i see the other
side of your face
so
what happened here and here petito told
the officer a backpack quote got her as
she tried to get in the back of the van
then the officer told her two witnesses
told them they saw brian laundry hit her
she said she hit him first
we want to know the truth if he actually
hit you
because you know i guess yeah but i see
him first where did he hit you
don't don't worry just feel like
my face is like
i guess
he didn't like hit me in the face
this is what laundry told the officer at
the beginning of the traffic stop i
don't want to try and defend myself by
saying anything everybody pushed her
away she gets really worked up and when
she does she swings and she had her cell
phone in her hand so i was just trying
to push her away the officers separated
gabby petito and brian laundry for the
night and did not file charges against
either one of them the officers then
discussed the incident among themselves
too many times women who are at risk
want to go back to their abuser they
just wanted him to stop and they don't
want to have to be separated they don't
want them charged they don't want to go
to jail and then they end up getting
worse and worse
treatment and then they end up getting
killed
in no way shape or form that i can
perceive
does what happened here a little slap
fight between
fiances who love each other want to be
together
can i perceive that this is going to
digress into the situation where he's
going to be a badder man
right but then again i don't have a
crystal ball
it's very hard to watch that now given
everything we know that's happened since
now the officers had explained to brian
laundry that a no contact order was
being issued to gabby petito meaning she
couldn't contact him until the next day
if she did she would face charges
laundry was being treated by those
officers as the victim in this case
brian
thanks angeannette joining us today is
professor of new york law school kirk
burkhalter and terry austin kirk as a
retired nypd detective what are you
seeing and hearing in this video that
may give clues as to what happened to
gabby potito
well first of all it is quite sad to
watch so here sounds kind of like a
classic battered woman's syndrome the
police officer identifies bruises i did
she says that she was grabbed in the
face but then she starts to backtrack
she's crying she's clearly upset but
then we hear uh further this officer
making this prediction that they were in
love and so forth uh it's quite possible
that there was a history of some type of
physical contact physical abuse
it doesn't appear in my experience that
this would be the first time that this
ever occurred and perhaps this got out
of hand absolutely terry hindsight is 20
20. but there's nothing you saw in this
video that makes you think the officers
should have arrested laundry then and
there right
that's right brian i don't think either
one of them should have been arrested
right then and there there's room for
debate here and hindsight is 2020. you
hear gabby saying she was the initial
aggressor but it could have been the
fact that she was afraid and didn't want
to talk about laundry as being the
aggressor then you also know that the
9-1-1 operator said something about the
fact that the witnesses were the ones
seeing that laundry was the aggressor so
these police officers were really trying
to take this information in determine
who was right or wrong they separated
them who would have known there was no
crystal ball like the officer said to
determine what would have happened as we
know today absolutely i think there's no
fault there on the officers and what
they did and jeannette what's the latest
on the search for brian laundry
well the fbi is still looking for brian
laundry we know that there's been a
search of that carlton reserve in
sarasota county it's a 25 000 acre
basically a swamp so they've been
looking for him there dog the bounty
hunter as we've been reporting has also
been searching for brian laundry so
there's really no sign of him that we
know of at this point and i do want to
mention uh that the moab police chief
has taken a leave of absence after this
video came to light and there's also an
investigation going on into the
officer's actions by an outside agency
so it'll be interesting to see what they
determine absolutely thank you for that
update and jeanette and thank you all a
high-profile ballet couple is accused of
sexually assaulting grooming and
threatening young dancers the court
pleadings allege long-term sexual
violence by former boston ballet star
dusty button and her husband mitchell
taylor button dating back to as early as
2010. five dancers have come forward and
allege the couple quote exploitated
their position and power of influence in
the dance world to sexually abuse young
dancers across the country some saying
taylor button groomed them with text
messages explicit comments and
separating dancers from their families
in all the couple faces 37 charges
against them their attorney has denied
all accusations
this week on the cop tales and cocktails
podcast sergeant sean stix-larkins sits
down with tulsa special operations team
commander mike eckhart after being
drafted by the new york yankees in 1988
eckert made a career change and found a
passion for law enforcement here's a
sneak peek of this week's episode when
urquhart recalls a friend who introduced
him to the world of policing
i was talking to danny frequently and he
was kind of relaying what this
experience was like
and the more i listened to him and the
more i recognized how excited he was
about what he was doing the more excited
i got
oklahoma city had a rule that you had to
be on the department for a year before
you could have a ride along
so we actually uh at the time had one of
those calendars that hung on our
refrigerator circled the date for his
year anniversary and i went down on the
road with them
you can listen to the cocktails and
cocktails now on apple podcast or
anywhere you can find podcasts still
ahead on law and crime daily murder
murder mystery reports now say maddie
murdoch met with a divorce attorney just
weeks before her murder but first friday
marks day 10 of the federal trial
against elizabeth holmes hear from our
legal analysts who break down the
defense and prosecutions case so far
[Music]
hi this is dan abrams with exciting news
for all of our law and crime followers
on youtube you can now get the live law
and crime network with youtube tv for
all of your daily live trial coverage
legal news expert analysis and original
true crime programs subscribe to youtube
tv today and then locate law and crime
in the channel guide and for only 1.99 a
month you can add the network to your
bundle
watch lawn crime every day with youtube
tv we put you in the jury box
[Music]
welcome back to law and crime daily
gripping testimony in the federal trial
against elizabeth holmes is taking a
stab at the functionality of theranosis
blood testing devices
this week jurors heard from former
theranos lab managers and associates
alike who said the edison device
promoted by theranose gave varied and
sometimes inaccurate results dr adam
rosendorff a former theranos lab manager
says he knowingly signed off on results
that were inaccurate after receiving
pressure from holmes and former ceo
ramesh sunni balwani rosendorf also
claimed the pair ordered lab workers to
stay inside with their doors closed when
government inspectors visited theranos
associate dr victoria sung testified her
company celgene stopped working with
theranos after just one month citing
various test results and validation
issues holmes found in the now defunct
theranos in 2003 claiming her edison
device would revolutionize blood testing
later tests found the device had many
issues holmes now faces 12 fraud charges
in connection to her time with the
company
let's bring back new york law professor
kirk burkhalter and terry austin terry i
wish we could have cameras in court
because supposedly lance wade holmes
attorney and the witness rosendorf got
into a little bit got into it a little
uh can you describe the tiff and how it
may have hurt the defense
sure rosendoff basically was trying to
say the technology was not ready and
that there were some quality control
issues
and then wade the attorney for the
defense basically was saying shouldn't
you have noticed that and he said then
he added a little jab about isn't that
why you get paid the big bucks then of
course rosendoff on the sand said
no but you get paid more and the jury
laughed you never want the jury to be
laughing at you so i think he should
have just held back and done more of a
straight
examination of that witness yeah you
want him to laugh with you and not at
you definitely a good rule of thumb kirk
the prosecution is putting forth what i
would describe as a russian doll of lies
there are no slide about tests to lie
about drug companies to lie to
pharmacies is there a defense for
prosecution like that there certainly is
and the defense is easy in theory but
certainly more difficult to execute
the job of the defense is to knock down
each and every piece of evidence that
the prosecution is setting forth so if
you accept those russian dolls she's
guilty however the prosecutors must pick
away at every little piece of evidence
in this case it's going to be quite
difficult because the evidence is it's
so high in volume
absolutely and stacking up more and more
it kind of reminds me like when you play
jenga maybe the defense can pull out one
piece and let the whole thing fall apart
but these jenga pieces seem to be as
heavy as a brick
thank you both the estate of the late
jeffrey epstein agrees to release a once
confidential agreement at the request of
an accuser heading to court against
prince andrew
virginia due phrase says prince andrew
sexually assaulted her in three
locations two of which were jeffrey
epstein's own properties drew frey says
epstein trafficked her and made her have
sex with his friends including prince
andrew in august she filed these claims
against the duke of york saying she was
17 years old at the time
now the previously sealed settlement
agreement between jufrey and the late
epstein will be released in prince
andrew's lawsuit after weeks of dodging
service prince andrew formally
stipulated that jufrey successfully
served him with court papers last week
and one more identification and one more
sentence have been issued for the
capital riots that occurred on january
6th 2021. clique keller an olympic gold
medalist who swam with michael phelps
was identified as one of the rioters in
the capitol by his former teammates and
coaches
at the time of the riots he was wearing
an olympic team usa jacket and an air
force veteran who posted a photo next to
nancy pelosi's office was sentenced to
45 days behind bars for his actions on
january 6th the judge thanked derek
jancar for his service the veteran
apologized for his actions and claimed
that he did not destroy anything in the
building and urge others not to as well
coming up on law and crime daily more
testimony from the meta knight murder
trial and newly discovered powerful
evidence plus the twisted crime web of
alec murdoch what's next for the
prominent south carolina attorney
following the deaths of everyone closest
to him
[Music]
welcome back it's a murder mystery that
has been captivating the nation with
even more twists and turns for alec
murda the prominent south carolina
lawyer is the subject of a convoluted
web of crimes back in june murdoch
called the police to report that he
found his wife maggie and his son paul
shot dead outside their home six weeks
before the murder it is alleged that
maggie murdoch met with lawyers to
discuss a divorce from her husband the
south carolina lawyer then resigned from
his law firm later revealing that he was
misappropriating funds during his time
there in september murdoch pulled over
to change a tire when a gunman shot at
him and grazed his head with a bullet
murdah later turned himself in admitting
that he hired a hitman to take him out
so that his surviving son could collect
an insurance payout all of this came two
years after his housekeeper mysteriously
died in a trip and fall accident at the
murder home gloria statterfield worked
at the home for over two decades before
her death upon her death there was a 500
thousand dollar wrongful death claim
filed against murder on her behalf of
her of her estate the state has not
received any of that money owed to
statterfield's children are now filing
for a motion that murda be arrested and
detained until the money he allegedly
embezzled from her estate is returned
let's bring back new york law school
professor kirk burkhalter and co-host
terry austin
terry jail or pay is that a thing that
could be the best way for the
statterfield estate to get the money
they're owed
i don't think putting someone in jail is
the best way to get the money that's
owed look they have a 500 000
settlement for a wrongful death claim
and in order to enforce that they need
that judgment and they need to file a
lien against the assets so they need to
locate assets and if they can do that
they can liquidate or sell the assets to
enforce that judgment that would be the
best way to go not necessarily putting
him in jail it could cause pressure but
they're not going to get any money by
doing that makes sense now professor
murder hasn't been charged with his
family's murder but with a hired hitman
and evidence his wife was looking to
divorce him should those murders be
reevaluated
if he hasn't been charged yes they
should be as long as evidence is still a
new evidence is still being uncovered
absolutely however
if it could have been done the first
time it's unlikely that this new
evidence just sheds such a bright light
however
i have no doubt that law enforcement
will be investigating this for quite
some time to come until he's formally
charged you know there's a lot of rocks
to overturn in this case we'll see what
happens as they continue to lift each
and every rock in the murder murder
mystery but of course we'll keep you
aware of each one of those as every
twist and turn continues in the murder
murder mystery
when we come back more on the meta
knight murder trial the damning search
history of a u.s airman accused of
murder more on the facebook pages he
visited before the body was discovered
[Music]
welcome back in florida the parkland
school shooter will stand trial on
monday for an unrelated crime where he
attacked a jail guard nicholas cruz
faces 34 counts of premeditated and
attempted murder for the shooting in
parkland florida in 2018 shooting the
shooting killed 17 students and staff
members in an unrelated incident cruz is
set to appear in court on monday for
attacking a jail guard nine months after
the shooting in a hearing on tuesday the
defense argued that this case should not
go to trial because the entirety of the
video and audio of the incident was not
preserved the judge denied this motion
ruling that there was no due process
violation the trial will begin on monday
with jury selection
and in arizona damning evidence is shown
on the stand against u.s airmen mark
gooch investigators say he sought out
missing persons reports and rewards
after mennonite sasha krauss went
missing 22-year-old gooch is charged
with theft kidnapping and first-degree
murder of krauss he pled not guilty on
all charges the sunday school teacher
was last seen in january 2020 near her
mennonite community in farmington new
mexico her body was found about a month
later near flagstaff arizona at the same
time gooch was stationed at an air force
base in phoenix experts say krause died
of blunt force trauma and a gunshot
wound to the head prosecutors say gooch
who was raised in the mennonite
community had disdain for the faith the
defense argues gooch traveled to the
mennonite community to reconnect with
the religion this week on the stand
investigators detail gucci's search
history revealing he sought out
information about krause's murder before
her body was found
note of the farmington police department
facebook page
the
san juan county sheriff's office
facebook page
and the farmington police department
facebook page
specifically the article referencing
or requesting information for
deceased
all right sasha krauss sasha cross
on the 2nd of february 2020
he
searched the farmington facebook
facebook page
specifically the article for missing
article of sasha krauss
and then on the 21st of february 2020
he started the farmington police
department facebook page article
specifically referencing a 50 000 reward
for information leading to
sasha krauss
kirk i know it's not an element of any
of his crimes but seeking the reward for
someone you're now accused of murdering
how odd or twisted is that
well it is very twisted it's odd however
the defense might use it as uh just in
the reverse well why would my client
seek out this reward if my client had
committed this crime however here you
have all the other searches in
conjunction with that so it's very odd
and it just goes to this really bizarre
behavior yeah i definitely expect the
prosecution to use that fact against him
along with the litany of facts they have
in this case terry how do you think the
prosecution will twist that fact to try
and convict gooch or do you think
there's an innocent explanation that the
defense can use
you know these computer searches are
very damaging for the defendant both the
content and the timing if in fact he is
doing a missing persons search after she
went missing the inference there is he
has information about where she is and
he wants a reward about that because
there was a reward that was put out for
that and if he's searching the computer
for information about a murder before
her body was found the inference there
is that he knows she was murdered so
either way i think the prosecution can
argue that he was searching something he
shouldn't have been and the defense can
just say maybe he was curious
yeah i think that's definitely a defense
that he could be put forward maybe he
was curious maybe he's just searching
like anyone else that may have been
looking for her but when you have such
strong circumstantial evidence aside
from that i think it'd be extremely
difficult for the defense to prevail on
that argument as you said terry just
fact upon fact upon fact that it's very
damaging
did you see any
mention by the defense of that may have
come from underneath this circumstantial
evidence though
you know i don't know just yet whether
or not they're going to find any
additional information based on these
searches i do think that they're going
to find additional information as far as
the timing of all of the driving that he
did all right well thank you for joining
us here on law and crime daily we'll see
you next time as we discuss justice in
america
[Music]
you